hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
gah and I'm Dan Seibert yeah
then cybertor my friend dan dan has his
own YouTube channel and gamer reviews
and stuff like that right he's
knowledgeable on games and I thought
what better video to introduce Dan on
than the witcher 3 trailer what a lot of
people have been asking us to check this
out
Laurens here she knows so much about
video games all over that she's oh dude
man this is NZ's aim perfect person to
have on this video she ever see she's
not just here because she's hot she's
here because she's also really
knowledgeable and again
yeah buttons and stuff she's really
buttons and stuff yeah she's awesome she
really knows please to hate me because
you'd call me a button masher
oh you're one of those oh I would
sometimes beat him so it works there's
no denying that it works but it's still
annoying yeah because I'm not like Oh up
down X triangle circle right trigger I
did this special move I'm just like like
I did a special move all right
this is such a baby I need the game so
let's watch this trailer I'm interested
to hear Dan's input I haven't watched it
yet I'm super excited super excited all
right guys
should I take off my glasses this is
like oh serious watching want people to
see my eyes that's what the lady's
coming for come here for the eyes you
know what's up babies Leah went on the
sexual commentary watch Laura look at my
eyes for a second now you're in love
with me that's what's happened I'm so
scared of like you for this long
oh wow now
wow this looks amazing that next-gen
graphics up it's so v1j among us legend
looks like yam it's a real person which
is it it looks like here I'll just
there's cool music look human on her
fake boobies beneath the ground be
creative by creating a this play
when I do
but uh show gives up she deserves
mountains don't use a carrot bad guys
he's a good guy
you're playing a good guy Jack you're
working for the eve okay you don't know
that
oh they're nakey whoa just like the
environment oh good lord
beers
everything here looks fantastic this
looks like a movie brought to life oh no
witches oh oh oh
did a bird just fly through his head a
bird - [ __ ] came out of his head oh
this is so weird this is a weird game do
you don't who looks like some babes like
real like epic fantasy brought to life
man I could love it
like a dark way going on Game of Thrones
this [ __ ] hopefully I got that right
I haven't seen Game of Thrones yet
really what yeah oh I mean oh quick to
save all the comments I just don't have
time to watch it because I know once I
start one episode I'm gonna forget yeah
yeah you have to prepare to disappear
for weeks anyway yeah no damn so what
are your thoughts on this Dan oh I love
next-gen graphics so much I mean we know
what that is I actually do know what
that is so shut the [ __ ] up now Jim what
is it next generation no I don't know
its Xbox one and PlayStation 4 no I
don't know idiot so no ice told them
that I would lie during this and pretend
I knew I was talking about of it there
don't want me to do that have a Secrets
Revealed it looks incredible it really
does just like every like the visuals
you Steven saw some gameplay and you can
barely tell the difference between the
gameplay and the cinematics that's a
great point yeah cuz I notice that -
where a lot of these game trailers are
always like cinematic clips these
cinematics like especially there were
few shots in there like straight out of
a movie and like the people look so rich
I mean I'm really only talking about the
graphics right now but I think that's
just what was best demonstrated in this
trailer is just like how real everything
looks like the characters faces have
like details not just like a blank skin
that was thrown on you could see like
freckles and the pores yeah yesses it's
so good it's so good
morning you it's this is wasted on yeah
it's just no I can totally appreciate
the graphics I mean I have an older
brother and so I grew up playing video
games and this was like 10 years ago
video games so I can see this and I can
definitely see how great the graphics
are so Oh game seven through so that's
my game back in my day we had 8-bit
pixels
Super Nintendo we brought you here to
pick on you
ah you're the butt of all our jokes now
are we allowed to high-five
yeah let's seriously talking about the
graphics uh yeah ya know you make a
great point with that I love the Arkham
Asylum game one thing that ball yeah
yeah yeah and one thing I really bummed
me out was how the cinematic graphics
were so [ __ ] awesome and then they go
to the game player like they just don't
look anywhere near as cool as a
cinematic graphics I like seeing that
they blend well together in this one
yeah it's a matter of power because uh
you know before with the Xbox 360 and
the PlayStation 3 you know we could
render out these really gorgeous like
cinematics because it's just like a
movie studio and though they can pump
out something that looks really good but
like when it comes to gameplay it has to
pull a lot back yeah and if you're
watching that just like the small
details like his hair while he was
walking was was wafting in such a
magnificent way back and forth and
you're just like that looks like real
hair yeah Dan dad dad please come in a
little more so that way we can see you
there we go sorry cheese
alright guys thanks for checking out our
video talking about you know The Witcher
3 why don't you uh put this subscribe
button up here see what technology is
done oh yeah leave it there horn there
we go good shot slowly moving over the
face hey guys you know what happens
after I say subscribe shout out shout
shout shout outs we do shout outs now
shall we do shout outs now I've watched
show before yeah I'm like you Lauren
i watch the show no no you don't say Joe
how you doing what happened on last
week's episode what was the cliffhanger
mm-hmm see he was disarming the bomb and
he had to choose between the orange wire
and the green wire but he's colorblind
you learned in that episode that I have
colored by yeah while watching the
trailer for Annie this is the same hand
you sure let them know it was a second
trailer and then people know the same we
killed off your character yeah yeah it
was it was Annie Annie er Chris Kara's
Ellis Kyra's honest I'm gonna skip a lot
of this stuff you're saying about Sally
cuz Sally isn't here guys
get up Brent Lauren's here now I never
disappointed you love your shows guys
coming you all the way from Big D Dallas
Texas I'm in Houston
yeah home of America's Team the
sorry-ass Dallas camber got my IMAX
tickets for Thursday and Friday night
wow this is a long time ago P so can NK
yeah shout out yes man yeah you asked
for this before Godzilla hear you're
finally getting it Chris cartas Ellis
you say solace to our seats overall they
are all the way from Big D down six H
towns where it's at gen Zilla or des
gens aloha gent dude if you don't give
me a shout you'll miss an opportunity to
get over Annika she just came in here
she's over she's great she's just right
right over there JK but I have oh what a
dick we can make a joke like that
nice serious offer but I have a channel
you should check out I do guitar what's
that what are you kidding me guitar it's
the most advanced time moon musical
instrument you've ever seen oh I do what
our covers and I'm gonna keep doing
those and move your review so stay tuned
cool man do you send us a link let's
check out your [ __ ] to Ghent Zilla guys
yeah usually man all right man cool I'm
so stupid I realize my chest was pushing
on your shoulder and then I thought I
was getting a boob graze from you know
that's not my boob at what that's like
nowhere oh my gosh doing Wow Reapers
reaction Empire Empire
said on edge of tomorrow trailer
reaction is this like the best movie of
the year like seriously this year's
pushing out a lot of extremely awesome
movies it's like the mother of movies
and labor XD a lot by the way bro how
far am i down on the shout out great as
always
my lover all right well dude we finally
got you up right now man did it your
life is complete ain't no mountain high
enough ain't no Valley low enough ain't
no River wide enough to keep me from the
same baby see no mountain high ain't no
Valley low ain't no River wide my baby
if you need me call me no matter where
you are no matter how don't worry baby
just call my name I'll be there in a
hurry you don't have to worry cuz baby
anyway we sing that for you because
you're the one climbing the mountain
into the shadows and you did it you did
it buddy put your flag down well guys I
feel like we accomplished a good video
today I did it I feel like yeah yeah
yeah we were if it was really necessary
but Lauren and I are the neighbors
really necessary